עכשיו שעברנו על כל המרכיבים של VQE, בואו
נסכם מה למדנו ונראה איך מחשב קוונטי מריץ את זה.
אנחנו מתחילים עם מצב הייחוס שבחרנו בחכמה, circuit פרמטרי,
בחירת פרמטרים ראשונית והמילטוניאן.
אנחנו מעבירים את אלה למחשב הקוונטי שלנו.
לפני שאפשר להריץ את ההמילטוניאן על מצב ה-ansatz,
אנחנו צריכים לעשות עיבוד מקדים קלאסי של ה-circuit
כדי להפוך אותו לקריא לחומרה קוונטית בתהליך שנקרא transpilation.
חשוב גם לנצל בצורה הטובה ביותר
את הארכיטקטורה של qubits בחומרה האמיתית כדי לקבל את התוצאות הטובות ביותר.
התהליכים האלה מטופלים לרוב אוטומטית כך שאנחנו לא
צריכים לדעת במפורש על קישוריות qubit,
רמות נאמנות gate וכן הלאה.
עכשיו המשימה היא למדוד את המצב המתקבל
ולהעריך את ערך הציפייה, שיעבור אופטימיזציה נוספת
על ידי מייעל קלאסי.
מדידה זו מתבצעת על ידי סיבוב בסיס המדידה
ואז שילוב תוצאות המדידה כדי לקבל את ערך הציפייה.
התוצאה הפרמטרית הזאת מוזנת אז
למייעל הקלאסי, שמוצא פרמטרים חדשים למצב.
ואז התהליך חוזר על עצמו.
עיבוד מקדים קלאסי יוצר circuit פרמטרי חדש
ואנחנו מיישמים את אותו המילטוניאן כמו קודם.
שימו לב שבכל תהליך ה-VQE אנחנו רק משנים את המצבים
דרך הפרמטרים שמתקרבים ומתקרבים למצב הבסיס.
אנחנו חוזרים על זה עד שאנחנו מרוצים מהתוצאה.
וזהו.
שמי Victoria Lipinska וזה היה קורס על variational quantum eigensolver.